The homework scores class may be useful for storing a single student's grades.
And you can get useful information out of a single student's scores. But when
my friend Sarel was teaching math, that wasn't enough information for her. She
wanted information about her teaching skills, as well as detailed summaries for
the students. She wanted to know how well she had taught fractions. And how
well she taught equivalent fractions. And for that, she would need to compare
the data for all of the students for one topic. This is starting to look like a
2-D array. With this structure it would be possible to calculate the total for
a student. And also to calculate the total for a topic, which would allow her
to compute sums for each topic. And then compare them, to see which topics she
needed to spend more time on. Once that was done, she could write very
detailed, customized teacher comments for each student, by looking at what they
got in each topic, and choosing different sentences based on that grade. We're
going to implement this together. I'm going to make a class. The GradeBook
class, which will contain a 2-D array, of all of the scores. It'll also
contain, the names of the students, and the names of the topics. Since you
probably don't want to enter these scores over and over again, I wrote a method
that will read the GradeBook scores, from the files, and put them into the
array for you.